Share of the cost sharing that still needs to come up.
That's not a lended amount.
That's not part of this.
Basically the last paragraph takes care of the case where the two numbers don't match at the end and then the town actually owes more than what's anticipated.
That has to be repaid and that's what that paragraph does.
Correct.
If I'm sorry.
Oh please go ahead.
Sorry.
The Senate Finance Committee added this paragraph D just to clarify that the full amount of whatever is lended would come back to the state, that this would be a zero-sum game for the state.
This wouldn't be a grant program.
This is purely a lended and borrowed and paid back program.
The terms of negotiation, and this is where Representative Lynn know, is asking questions about this, and I think it would be limited to just the timing of the payments, you know?
So if it's not forgiveness of any of the amount, unless you deleted that first sentence of paragraph D, subparagraph D, or interest, because the way this bill's written, there's no interest.
So it's really just the timeline of when that difference would get paid back, which in theory shouldn't exist if the estimates were done well.
Well, but you know what?
That's not the way that the senator— Representative Lynn, did you want to say something?
I'm sorry.
May I be heard?
Thank you.
That doesn't—that's not the way the senator—I'm sorry, I'm forgetting her name now.
But Prentice, that's not the way she interpreted it.
I mean, she sort of said that it would be a question of whether it all had to be paid back or something less than all.
And it does seem like the DRA rule basically says if there's a dispute, the town loses in the end.
And that's kind of why I proposed that language, because if they really do get to loggerheads and they can't come to an agreement, then, you know, I mean, the way it is now, what would happen is the town would lose if under the language I proposed, they could go to court and the court would decide what's fair under the circumstances.
Maybe the town would collect the whole thing.
I mean maybe the town would have to pay back the whole thing.
Maybe it wouldn't.
It would depend on the circumstances.
And we could you could amend this bill to to make it so the state wouldn't always be entitled I guess if you will or required to to get the amount back.
I'll just point out on subparagraph D and this was an intent of the bill as passed recipients of the exceptional disaster relief loan shall be responsible to pay the entire loan amount to the state.
This wasn't designed to have a mechanism that the municipality would ever pay back less than it borrowed.
If you wanted to open this up that that could be you know if in the event the municipality's reimbursement from FEMA was less than it's borrowed and you want to have a mechanism for forgiveness, I think that would require a further amendment than what's in front of you now.
Representative Petrie.
Yeah, thank you, Madam Chair.
I get a question.
Now, are we talking about the day before status of the roads or whatever bridges or the mitigated, in other words, up to a repair where it's going to, or mitigated repair?
I don't have the answer to that.
That would be something we would want to speak to the Homeland Security Emergency Management folks as far as the definitions of allowable costs or those sorts of things.
Because that was mentioned, but I don't think they really specified.
I do know that they've got mitigation funds available for the communities.
I would think this whole area should be applying for mitigation funds because if they don't, it's going to happen again.
It's going to happen again.
And I think, you know, they mentioned Alstead, which was a total disaster.
And FEMA provided mitigation funds.
So I guess that if it was up to me, I would add something in here that says, if you are facing this kind of a disaster, then you need to apply for mitigation funds so that it doesn't happen again.
You know, I don't know what, you know, I don't know how to word that, but I do feel that, you know, sometimes, you know, the flood happens, okay, it's over, and that's it.
Thank you.
towns, you know, the flood happens.
Okay, it's over, and that's it.
So, if I may.
Go ahead.
So, this is a separate fund?
This 409 is a separate fund?
It's not this mitigated program that you're talking about?
No, the mitigation funds are FEMA money.
Oh, that's strictly FEMA.
Yeah.
Okay.
And we talked about it when we were dealing with 1665, but that's just my feeling.
So, Kate, I'm sorry, Representative Murray.
Thank you.
Yeah, this sounds like it's just to get the ball rolling so that you can get money, and it sounds like it should function as a pass-through almost so that there's no difference in the amount of money of what you get for the loan and what's going to come in and it just passes back.
But the way I read this or my understanding of it is that this is to get funds to the community as quickly as possible, knowing the money's going to come back in and just pass through.
So that seemed to be, that's my understanding of the goal of this, which is why I like the simplicity of it.
And I guess I don't know how to fit in your comments with mitigation money.
That seems like that's a little bit further down the road and that this is to get money to the communities to start work.
It seems to be the critical hiccup here.
I guess the only thing that I would say is that if a community is approved for this type of loan, then following something or other, you know, that mitigation funds must be applied for.
And if you receive mitigation or if you don't receive mitigation funds or whatever, if you don't apply for it and this happens again, then you're not eligible for this anymore.
I'd go for that.
You know, I mean, obviously that's very crude, but I know Mickey can fix it.
Okay, yes.
Just quickly, this expedites the process, but does it expedite it fast enough?
That's my question to Senator Prentice.
Again, we have that two-week window where the governor can't just on the spot say, I'm gonna be here and I'm gonna bring money with me so you can start fixing things tomorrow.
You know you're gonna have at least a two-week window.
Do we wanna put in anything about some kind of flexibility for the governor and GNC?
Or maybe I'm just over, it just seems to me like what you went through, that if they had had some immediate, an immediate resource.
Yeah, they did.
Okay, it wasn't like they were left high and dry.
The state provided, I don't know what, anyhow, temporary assistance.
Okay.
So everything's covered then?
I think so.
All right.
You know, maybe it wasn't as much as they wanted, but the state did at least help in some, to some degree.
And of course, the state was responsible for all the state roads.
The problem is not the state roads.
The problem are the town roads.
And whether or not they were, you know, whatever.
Please, go ahead.
Thank you.
Can I ask Representative Aaron?
Of course.
I mean, two weeks isn't a very long time, and at some point you have the disaster, but it's still going to take a little bit of time to figure out what needs to be done to triage the situation.
And it seems like within the two-week, that may well, you know, be within a two-week period, and then you've got plenty of time for the next Governor's meeting to come up.
So was it, you know, as a two-week, did you, you know what I'm asking?
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
And to your question, what happened immediately after this flooding hit us was, of course, we had our own municipal emergency management team go out and take a look at what was going on.
And they were able to determine, and they worked with our local EMTs because we needed to make sure that we could get to where people needed us.
So they went through and they did a quick assessment of what roads were open, which ones were damaged, which ones had to get signage to close them and so forth.
And of course meeting with the select board.
But to your question, then, we, in terms of getting immediate funding, we had money in our fund balance.
We had $450,000, $550,000.
So they knew that they at least had a small pot of money to be able to use or tap into right away in order to get roads open with gravel and whatever.
We also contacted Homeland Security Emergency Management and Department of Transportation and started to work with them.
I know the commissioner of the Department of Transportation, Victoria Sheehan, right away diverted a lot of resources to that part of the state.
So we were able to get Jersey barriers, we were able to get signs, road clothes signs.
They couldn't give us trucks or gravel or any of that kind of thing.
But we had a certain limited amount of resources that we were able to tap into.
So I guess the two weeks is manageable, I think.
I mean, unless there's something even more horrendous that could happen to a municipality other than total washout of floods.
So, yeah, I think that that's doable.
Mickey, I have a question.
As you know, I DON'T LIKE TO LEAVE FISCAL OUT OF MONEY SPENDING.
SO DOES ANY PLACE IN THIS SAY THAT FISCAL DOESN'T NEED TO BE INVOLVED?
IT DOESN'T EXPLICITLY SAY FISCAL DOESN'T HAVE TO BE INVOLVED, BUT THE CURRENT LOAN PROGRAM, THE WAY IT'S IN THE STATUTE NOW, IT'S JUST A GOVERNOR AND COUNCIL PROCESS.
SO THEY CAN SPEND OUR MONEY EVEN IF WE DON'T WANT THEM TO?
THEY CAN SPEND IT TO THE EXTENT THAT IT'S EXPECTED BACK.
THIS IS WHY THERE'S NO FISCAL NOTE ON THIS BILL.
THIS IS A NET ZERO PROGRAM.
So this is expected to be returned.
If it's lended, it's a receivable and it will be paid back in whatever the timeline of the.
Okay.
So if the governor and council wants to forgive any of this, then it would have to come back to fiscal?
Currently, the way the bill came to you, there is no forgiveness mechanism, and there would be no fiscal, there's no mechanism here for forgiveness in the way I read it.
So the expectation would be a net zero.
Because you can't, if you forgive, then you can't get FEMA money, is what I heard them say.
Okay.
All right.
So, okay.
Go ahead.
They did the original text of the legislation had fiscal.
So it was the Senate that amended it to take fiscal out and put it in government council.
So we can always change it if that's something that we want to do.
I will say that the Senate added it as new language and just reverted it back to the existing language.
So it's always been, fiscal's never been part of this program.
And I think just, and I'll just point out as far as concerns about timing and expediting the process, GNC does meet more routinely than fiscal does too.
And I think FISCAL DOES, TOO.
I THINK THAT WAS PART OF THE REASON SENATE FINANCE DIDN'T WANT TO ADD AN EXTRA APPROVAL PROCESS.
FISCAL WILL MEET ON A DIME.
I'M SORRY.
I SAID ON A DIM.
OKAY.
YES, GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU, MADRIC CHAIR.
I HAD A QUESTION FOR REPRESENTATIVE AARON.
HOW MUCH DID YOU HAVE IN YOUR CAPITAL RESERVE FUND FOR YOUR ROADS AND BRIDGES AND WHATEVER?
We had a bridge fund that had, I want to say, reserve fund for your roads and bridges and whatever?
We had a bridge fund that had, I want to say, I think it was $90,000 that we had saved for our bridges.
It was a bridge fund.
And the bridge on Forest Road, we had a temporary deck put on there a couple of years ago because the bridge was red-listed and we didn't have enough money to replace the bridge.
So best we could do was put this slab on top.
Well, this flood washed away all of the material that was underneath the slab.
So it's a culvert, and it had material on top, and then they had the slab, and all that material was washed away.
So we were able to tap in $60,000, I think it was, to blow in material underneath to shore up that decking.
So we were able to use that from our capital reserve fund that we had for the bridge.
And the reason why we only had $90,000 in that fund was because we had recently replaced a bridge elsewhere in town two years prior.
So we were building up that fund again.
WE DID OF COUR, have other funds for road repair set aside.
We do have capital reserve funds, but with a town of 850 people and limited taxing ability, because we have certainly other projects and things going on that we have to pay for, It's a slow accumulation of funds in these capital reserve funds.
So we used whatever we had in our savings to deal with that.
And now this very same bridge, this Forest Road Bridge, we've just gotten notice from the state that if we don't have a plan in place to replace the entire bridge, they will close it.
So now we're scrambling around in town to try and figure out how we can, well, to first of all get a plan in place and how we are going to get the money available to do this to replace this bridge.
We are thinking that perhaps this might be a FEMA reimbursable project, but they are now balking at the RFP process and the engineer that's working on it, and there's all kinds of complications about, you know, why FEMA may not help us with this at all.
Okay.
Mickey, I know you have answers to every question I ever ask.
How much do these small towns receive in municipal bridge and road aid?
So we have a State Aid Bridge Program.
That's to repair.
That's a matching program, 80-20.
And that's, we have a reoccurrence of $6.8 million a year for that program.
As far as just highway block grant aid, that's in the ballpark of $34, $35 million a year.
That's the apportionment A that we refer to.
Those are the two programs that jump out at the top of my head right now for such things.
Okay.
So can the bridge aid be targeted, or is that just, or I mean the town just has to come up with a 20.
Yeah, it's there's a, there's a queue.
There's a list, I think, uh, for projects.
And I think it's part of the 10 year plan project as well.
And I'm not sure how far out we are at this point with it.
I haven't got an update on that for a, for a little bit for myself.
So it would make sense that for this bridge, they go to the 10-year plan and see if they can get it updated?
Yeah.
If it's something that town wanted to apply for bridge aid, they certainly could go through that process.
Well.
Yeah.
And I will, I mean, there is another bill, I think it was referred to criminal justice and public safety that has a $36 million appropriation to the state bridge program and another $30 million for the apportionment A program as well.
So there's another piece of legislation with funding for those two programs.
Okay.
May I make a comment on?
You can say whatever you want.
We're very open here.
Thank you.
Remember I told you the Forest Road Bridge, which is the bottom of my driveway.
The Forest Road Bridge, we put a slab on top.
The reason we did it that way was because we had originally went to the road and bridge fund, where they, you know, it's the 80-20 match kind of thing.
And we had gotten an estimate from the state, and the state had their engineers come up with this plan that was going to cost the town, I think, two and a half million dollars to put a bridge over this, to put a new bridge in.
And certainly we had no, we didn't have the resources to meet even the match that this program would have required.
Plus, the waiting list on this program was quite long.
and um so the town came up with this other way to fix this, which was to put a slab over, which only cost us about $60,000.
So we felt that this temporary fix was going to get us through until we could save money to actually do an actual bridge repair replacement.
And that's the problem that these smaller towns have, is that they just don't have the resources to do the work that either the state is recommending us do or that has to be done.
It just takes a long time to accumulate the funds to be able to do these kinds of things in the proper way that they're supposed to be done.
So that's what happened.
All right.
If I'm hearing everybody, we have no problem with this bill except for a couple of amendments.
Is that correct?
I have no problem with everything except I still have a question on line 7.
Maybe Mickey has the answer.
The rest of it I think should stay as is myself.
I still have questions about the anticipated assistance.
She described it as nine months to a year before FEMA would have an idea of how much that is, yet we're talking two weeks.
So who makes under this, and I know this is existing language, who now makes the anticipated assistance assessment?
I think this is a question best for Homeland Security and emergency management, but I know it's part of the initial preliminary assessing of the damage they do.
And I think Fallon did point out that subparagraph C, where it's kind of an extra guardrail in there to really try to hone in on, I don't know if conservative is the right thing, but really try to ensure whatever the amount of this loan is, there's a very good expectation that it would be covered under a FEMA reimbursement.
Which is exactly my point or concern.
If, I mean, I'm fine with the bill as it is, but as I read this bill, I'm looking at a very long timeline before this becomes eligible, which, again, I don't personally have a problem with, but if the majority here is thinking that this is something that's going to be done in weeks, I don't see that happening.
I would say that FEMA does, FEMA, the state FEMA, if that's the right term, that's probably the wrong term, comes in and does a preliminary assessment to say that we anticipate, what did they say, 6 million?
18 million?
18.
Yeah.
That that was their preliminary assessment.
And so, okay, but it doesn't matter.
That gives the towns a anticipated assistance amount.
So I mean, that is all done.
I mean, when the Saco overflowed and destroyed a bunch of stuff up there, the preliminary assessment was done within a week.
And so whether the governor and council can put it on the agenda the following week, I don't know.
But that's up to them.
And I don't know if you guys are all, if you're good with it, would there be a way to clarify that anticipated assistance by, as determined by X?
And I don't know who the department, to me it's just open ended and it's kind of vague.
Yeah, that's me.
I can find out from the department if that, that may be a federally defined term, you know, so that anticipated assistance may be, may have a definition behind it that I just don't know right now that could help this conversation, but I can reach out to them and get more info.
And other than that particular two words, I'm good with the rest of the bill.
Just a question about, um, commissioner Sheehan was at your side, bringing resources immediately.
Does there need to be any clarification or Mickey, do we have a law already in place that gives her that authority to act or that state services are, the governor has the authority once he declares an emergency that he releases the support systems that would be available.
But it sounds like Victoria Sullivan even got their, Victoria, no, no.
Sheehan.
Oh, my God.
You can tell too much in my life.
Victoria Sheehan.
That was bad.
So she acted to get you some support right away.
I think that part of the disaster planning that...
That's in there.
That's all in there.
Perfect.
Okay.
Good.
You know, and it's managed by the Homeland, Jennifer and Fallon.
It's managed by that, just like Perry Plummer used to do.
One further question.
Now we've got another bill coming, 402, that I guess deals with the same content.
I'll tell you what 402 is if you want.
SB 402 is a bill that was put forth, I believe by Senator Kahn.
And what that sought to do was to take that 25% FEMA match and make half of it shareable.
The state picks up 12.5% and the municipality picks up 12.5% so that the municipality's not responsible for the whole 25%.
And I think, and what happened was that got stalled in the Senate Finance Committee because New Hampshire Homeland Security Emergency Management could not tell them how much 12.5% represented in dollars for the state.
Well, I think they passed that through.
I think it is coming over here.
And I think they may have changed it to say that no matter what the match is, the state picks up half.
It just seems like we have a lot of these bills in.
They're interconnected.
Would it be nice to look at them as a package?
Yeah.
But the problem, when are all the bills due for second committee?
I don't have my schedule here.
I thought it was April 14.
No?
I think you're right.
And then those will go to the floor the following week, except that's when we have to have all our bills done.
So I'm not sure if these would be considered bills going to a second committee or not.
I don't know if there would be a second committee for either of these.
The deadline for bills to report bills going to a second committee is the 14th, and the last day to report on all bills is the 28th.
Yeah, because ours are due on the 28th.
These bills are due on the 28th.
And I'll just clarify.
So Senate Bill 402 started as the state sharing that cost share with the municipalities.
Senate Finance did amend to create a essentially a new mechanism for the governor with fiscal and governor council or and council approval to draw on funds not otherwise appropriated to provide disaster assistance to municipalities so somewhat similar to the civil emergency that's in law now but this is really just targeted for fema related disasters not necessarily the declaration of a civil emergency.
So they created an easier pathway for response for situations like this.
Okay.
All right.
So, Mickey, you don't have to rush too fast on the amendments to this because we don't have any other bills other than this one.
And it's not due till the 28th.
We'll just, you know, I mean, if we could get it in by the 14th, we could, but we don't have to.
So.
I mean, if we could get it in by the 14th, we could, but we don't have to.
So I don't know what people's schedules are.
I've got a, we're gonna have a pre-fiscal on Wednesday the 13th.
And I haven't set a time for that.
We've got an issue, but does the 13th sound like it might work?
Thank you.
sound like it might work.
So I will, I'm waiting to hear from HHS on something, because they want to come and brief us on the Hampstead Hospital so we'll figure all that out so here can I just raise it so am I understanding correctly then that the the set the consensus is that subsection D as it's written now requires the repayment of the whole loan under any circumstances and that we should leave that in because if we take if we try to take that out there'll be some we might be jeopardizing the FEMA money so is that everybody's okay so then forget about my language that we don't need that yeah we can't we can FEMA MONEY.
I GUESS WE COULD.
ANYHOW, I WILL FIGURE OUT WHAT TIME ON WHATEVER DAY THAT IS, THE 13TH.
I AGREE WITH REPRESENTATIVE TURKOT YET AGAIN OF BEING COMPLETELY FINE WITH THIS.
I'M HERE ON WEDNESDAY LATE IN THE DAY IF THAT MATTER that matters to anybody, as opposed to, let's not meet at nine in the morning.
Actually, the afternoon would be better for me that day, too.
By the way, I don't set nine o'clock meetings, okay?
So, yeah, I'll see what works out.
But like 2 o'clock or 2.30 or something like that would be.
Okay.
So I'll look at that, see what, you know, mesh all that together.
And we'll try to do that.
Some of us will be here for fiscal all day.
Okay, may I have a pen?
If I may, Madam Chair, I just want to thank the committee for all the work you're doing on this and addressing this very important issue.
You're quite welcome.
Thank you.
.